as we look at all of this the prime
minister is talking about an abundance
of caution
in effect which begs the question if we
have to be that cautious why are we
changing the rules in the first place
so it's always going to be a balance um
and that was the whole point of the road
map
when the prime minister announced that
on the 22nd of february there were these
five-week
staging posts and the reason that it
took five weeks was that we had to look
at the evidence
today i'm very pleased that we're
reopening
but clearly in order to reopen on the
21st we're going to have to see
the data now there's nothing that we've
seen so far
that suggests that we're going to have
to postpone that but of course
there has to be some flexibility because
we don't know what the
coronavirus will do it's this strange
situation where i mean smart wallport
told
sophie ridge yesterday and he's a former
uh
government chief government scientific
advisor say my advice is just because
you can do something doesn't necessarily
mean you
should well in essence when things are
reopened people aren't going to
pay much heed to that are they because
people want to get out they want to
hug a loved one yeah i mean that's
completely understandable but
it's it's not that different what sir
mark was saying to
the prime minister's uh urge for caution
so yes uh things are being opened up but
people should
have common sense uh they should uh
use uh judgment and i think if we
act in a reasonable way there's no
reason to just suppose that we can't
reopen the economy entirely on the 21st
of june
i think it's got to be a degree of of
common sense bit of caution
and not people you know people shouldn't
be running away
uh getting too exuberant i suppose i
think we just need to be measured
and cautious yeah i mean the problem is
when you when you rely on
the great british public to exercise
that common sense well that
that's all well and good and a lot of
people will but we all know there will
be people who won't
i mean and this is potentially where
that you get your problems and your hot
spots isn't it
yes i mean there's always a balance as i
say and you can't uh
compulsory uh lock everything down
forever
uh that's why we had a road map we want
to reopen in a safe
cautious way and i think this is a good
way to do that i mean will you be
heading out to a restaurant have you met
if you made plans have you made plans to
meet up and give some people a hug but
you haven't seen him for a while
gonna be back in my constituency uh i
can't name the pub
but it'll be it'll be a lot of fun i'm
sure yeah but it'll be moderate i mean
i'm not gonna be there
with huge uh hosts of people no
no i'm sure not you would have done a
lot of trouble if you overdid it
and can we have a look at the travel
situation because obviously again a lot
of people
very pleased about that and and being
able to sort of head abroad for the
first time
in a in a long time but do you agree
with matt hancock who said
just don't travel to one of the amber
countries like spain
yeah i think i think matt obviously
being health secretary is
firmly on top of the detail and the
numbers
and i think what he says makes sense
again people are allowed
to do things but it doesn't mean that
everybody should be should be going away
at the same time
i think the urge for caution makes sense
i think what matt
is saying is that yes you can go to
another country but it would probably be
advisable at this stage not to
i mean you sort of wonder if it would
have been more sensible if if that's the
general approach you know the advices
don't go
then why not just sort of ban travel to
any country that isn't on the green list
well of course you could have be ultra
safe and just simply
forget about the log uh forget about
easing up and just continue with the
lockdown
we've decided that that wasn't the right
course
again there's a balance between opening
things up uh
urging people to exercise caution and do
opening things up safely and that's
that's a good balance i think
but in terms of that caution i mean
you'll be aware that i mean there's
there's a fair amount of concern of how
we reacted to
the india variant i mean the uh
civil aviation authority figures suggest
900 people arrived every day from india
between april the 2nd and april the 23rd
but it wasn't even on the red list so
they weren't even being put in a
they weren't even being put in in hotel
accommodation
they had to quarantine and self-isolate
and then then on the 23rd of april
uh we we put it um on on the red list
before the variant had actually been
identified
um are we confident that the the
vaccination program
is enough to deal with the indian
variant have you got any information on
that
um again matt hancock said yesterday
very clearly that he had a lot of
confidence
that the vaccination does work against
the indian
variant but of course we can't
definitively prove anything until
we've eased up and see what the the
actual data shows
and that's why we've got a degree of
flexibility but there's nothing in the
evidence now that we've seen
that suggests the vaccine uh isn't very
effective against the indian
variant i mean obviously we know that
the the state of vaccination in this
country
is very good um but in in hot spots
like bolton where there is real concern
over the indian variant particularly in
a place like bolton
um they seem to be in a position now
where they're vaccinating
anybody who wants it they're sort of
encouraging anyone to come forward
do you approve of that does the
government approve of that no i think
the government has very clear guidelines
in terms of the ordered way in which we
roll out the vaccine
and as you said that's been working it's
been a very effective
uh rollout and we would suggest that uh
people should do it in
in the in in the correct order in the
right way but would you i mean
would the government try to put pressure
on an authority like bolton to stop that
then
i i don't know the actual details of
what's going on in bolton but i don't
think uh you know we've got very firm
guidelines
and we want people to follow this but it
i mean what they're obviously actively
trying to do
is is stop the spread of the indian
variant of monsieur amongst the younger
population
and as a result try to avoid the
possibility at least of a local lockdown
for that area i mean
but if they if if they can source the
vaccines to do that
isn't that a wise approach i can see
what they're trying to do uh
i can see exactly what they're trying to
do but what i've said is that
i think there's a really good way that
we've managed to roll out the vaccine
you yourself acknowledged
that it's been very successful and we
would suggest urge people
to follow the the guidelines that we've
set out and the method
that we've used within all of this um
obviously i mean
within within your remit i mean the
hospitality sector has been so badly hit
they're looking forward to getting up
and running a lot more at the moment
i mean there's a report claiming 10 of
restaurants have closed down the last
thing anyone wants to do is
is reopen to be shut down again but
there's no guarantee is there
that that come june we may have to look
at all this again
yeah we've been very clear that's why
they're with a five-week
staging post there's got to be
flexibility but as business secretary i
know
and i hear it every day the immense
pressure
that hospitality and retail uh has has
experienced i mean there's a huge amount
of
uh anxiety jobs people want to open up
the economy so that they can get trading
again and get back to normality and i
completely understand that
that's why we had the road map and
that's why i fully expect that will be
reopened
on the 21st of june you are you still
think despite the concern over indian
variant that
that that could happen i think i think
it's very likely to happen i said that i
think the vaccines
are working against the indian variant i
think we've got to look at the numbers
so we've got some flexibility
but there's nothing that i've seen and
there's nothing that the prime minister
has seen up to now
that suggests that we we we're going to
delay that 21st of june date
i mean the problem is though is that you
look at people heading out and about
i mean it's not exclusively the younger
end of the population who haven't been
vaccinated
but it's more likely to i mean i'm i'm
in my forces and i don't feel like going
out anymore
um it's it's yourself well i know
but it is likely to be the younger
unvaccinated people who are going to go
out isn't it yeah look there are risks
in this
um and and we we can't say now
we can't guarantee that everything will
be fine what we can do
is and we've said this consistently is
that we'll look at the data
and we'll make judgments according to
the data that we see so far so good
we're reopening
uh on the 17th of may as we said we
should in the way that we said we would
and now we have to see what happens
ahead of the 21st of june
i'm confident that we'll be able to get
to the 21st of june and open up
normally but i can't guarantee that now
okay minister good to talk to you this
morning thank you